vingt candidats et seulement cinq
finalistes les startups francilienne
présente ce mardi 13 décembre au café
théâtre de la royale factory avec
quelques minutes seulement pour
présenter plusieurs années de travail
parmi les concurrents du soir squeeze
une entreprise yvelinoise qui conçoit et
commercialise une gourdes réutilisables
pour la famille on souhaitait quand même
j'irai arriver à une une solution
beaucoup plus responsable beaucoup plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et qui
aussi avait un coût beaucoup plus limité
parce que mine de rien le budget gourde
à usage unique est quand même très élevé
lorsqu'on a pas mal d'enfants pour
écouter départager les orateurs
innovants plus d'une centaine de
potentiels investisseurs et décideurs
économiques étaient présents dans la
salle versaillaise il faut que les gens
se rencontrent se révèle et open innove
est un véritable révélateur d'un côté
c'est à dire qu'on met en avant met en
lumière des compétences et des talents
sur le territoire dont des start up
innovantes mais çà çà çà suffit pas il
faut aussi connecter les gens et on se
présente avec aux playoffs commun un
connecteur de compétences prix du jury
de cette soirée dédiée à l'économie
circulaire la boîte à champignons une
entreprise basée dans les yvelines qui
permet grâce à un simple processus
écologiques de produire soi-même ses
champignons une reconnaissance et un
encouragement à continuer c'est un
encouragement à avancer toujours dans le
même sens et à être fidèle à ce qu'on a
pensé au début on a pas pervertir le
projet a pas le travestir pour le faire
baisser le niveau on doit continuer à ne
voir ce niveau d'exigence et a pris
comme celui là bas nous encourageons
sens là également lauréat du prix public
phoenix propose une gestion
éco-responsable des invendus des
entreprises